all right you are looking live at the
rio grande valley
as border patrol is rounding up a group
of
migrants yeah uh as you can see we've
got uh the
unbelievable a drone shot uh what is
interesting about this
is you know uh once upon a time
the migrants would race across the
border and then scatter but now what
they're doing
is they are waiting in place for the
border patrol to turn themselves in
because
if you're an unaccompanied migrant child
or a family for the most part it's going
to be the easy pass to get into the
united states just turn yourself in they
will process you at one of those
jail-like facilities that is overcrowded
and the next stop ainsley is someplace
in america
that's right that's right we're seeing
uh some single individuals coming in
we're seeing
unaccompanied children and we're also
seeing families and most of the families
if you look at the numbers
from this past february compared to last
february it was here in the rio grande
valley
let's bring in tucker carlson he is host
of tucker carlson tonight hey tucker
oh good morning good morning we miss you
on the morning show
but we're proud of you for all your
success what do you make of what's
happening down there on the border is
that our biggest
issue right now well yeah because unlike
so many issues we
face right now this one will we know for
certain
change the country forever i mean the
stakes couldn't be higher the question
of who lives here is the central
question it's the democracy
so when you change the population you
change the outcome of the vote
which means you you change the way the
country is run and that's of course the
whole point of this
you know this country has gained 100
million
people in the last 30 years most
americans aren't even aware of that so
we've had massive demographic change
it's not enough for the people in charge
and so this is
this is an effort basically to pack the
electorate i mean let's
so if you open the borders and then
sponsor legislation giving citizenship
and voting rights to the people you've
just admitted
illegally what are you doing you're
trying to to change election outcomes
and that's what they are doing i think
that's a point um but however for people
who think the hispanic vote goes
automatically to democrats they didn't
pay attention to the last election
because you know the president's picking
up a lot of a lot of precincts in texas
in particular
i think eight in all mostly hispanic in
the last election not enough
they're getting about nine thousand
tucker nine thousand illegal immigrants
daily currently we have eleven thousand
children unaccompanied eleven thousand
plus children more like twelve
uh in uh hhs and 5767 is cbp
i don't understand you maybe could see a
bigger picture better than
than i can how does this help president
biden's administration
he wants to talk about what has got him
70
approval rating the 1.9 trillion dollars
that he just got he wants to talk about
all his programs but all everybody else
wants to talk about even democrats
and other networks is this how does this
help joe biden
well i think it helps the democratic
party long term again
the democratic party is extremely
frustrated by the idea that there are
americans who don't vote for them who
reject their program so if you change
the nature of the people who live here
then you win
forever so they really do think in
longer terms
i think i mean we're only two and a half
months into the administration at this
point
so i mean they're thinking 10 years
ahead
which is the way they think i mean they
think in a in a much broader way than
your average republican politician i
would say
the question is what is happening to all
these people where are they going
we know that a lot of them aren't
staying at the border they're being
flown into the interior of the country
there's evidence and i think we're going
to have the story tonight at 8
that some of these kids are being placed
in foster families
in states very far from the u.s border
if that's true it's an amazing story now
part of the problem is
the media aren't covering this partly
because they got biden elected and they
don't you know they don't want to hurt
his administration so soon into it
partly because there's been a news
blackout
on what's happening at the border but
you have to ask this is a huge number of
people and unprecedented number of
people
where are they exactly they're not all
in texas arizona new mexico and
california
well tucker you know there's a news
blackout because during the trump
administration
when there was that one image of those
kids in that room
that had the chain-link fence enclosure
you know the media melted down and said
it's kids in cages
they're essentially in the same cages at
the same facilities but there's not the
outcry that we saw before and what's
different about now
is it's the same conditions but there's
a global pandemic
and the news this morning out of the
white house is that apparently the
president
of guatemala is worried about the kids
and the families coming into guatemala
who might have covet which is ironic
because the biden administration
released
untold legions of migrants in the united
states without
ever testing for coven so on one hand
tucker carlson you got the president
saying
we got to cut we got to bring an end to
coven but at the same time it's like
okay the loophole is everybody needs to
worry about covet except the people who
are coming in
to our southern border illegally and
just check in with
border patrol so right in order to hold
a job or find an airplane you have to
get a vaccine
and wear a mask after you get a vaccine
and remain
in terror of the virus after you get the
vaccine
but people from foreign countries can be
admitted without any testing at all i
mean it's just yet another example
of the intense focus on foreign
nationals
to the exclusion of the interests of
american citizens i mean there are like
600
000 americans sleeping on the street
every night they're homeless
no one seems to care no one seems even
to notice they're there unless you
happen to live in a big city and your
park's been taken over by a tent city
and yet we're paying for hotel rooms for
foreign nationals who broke our laws to
get here look
it's no attack on people who wrote a
train from belize to get here at all
but it's if you're running the u.s
government you got to care about u.s
citizens first and foremost that's your
job but they don't
well look what's happening in california
in san diego and you're from
california so you can weigh in on this
story the convention center there
they're asking taxpayers
to keep your kids at school who haven't
been in school for
more than a year you need to keep
zooming or virtual learning
but your tax dollars need to go toward
the migrant children who are here
illegally
we're going to pay for them to get an
education
asking teachers to come to the
convention center and volunteer
in person because they're on spring
break right now to come in and teach the
migrant children how do you feel about
that
well i mean it's one of the i mean
keeping american children out of school
for a year
is one of the cruelest things this
country has ever done
and it tells you the power of the
teachers unions there's almost nobody
who's for that there's no scientific
basis for the policy
it's killed a lot of people i mean
mental health
issues among children have skyrocketed
exactly right and you've interviewed
we've interviewed parents of kids who've
killed themselves
because the isolation of the lockdowns
and yet
they're putting once again the priority
on foreign nationals and again it's not
against
migrant kids but the extent to which
they ignore
american kids is shocking and by the way
california has gained
10 million people net since 1990 10
million
has the state gotten nicer no it's
gotten much worse
immigration is the main driver of
population growth in california people
who are born there are leaving
and the state every year gets worse for
the middle class
no one is standing back and asking how
is this going to improve our country
it's not and no one is even arguing that
it is
i really think republicans need to wake
up and see the big picture here which is
the country will be changed forever and
no one is making the case that it will
improve
and the thing is it's opportunity too
because hey i gave you time to run your
state in california
what you gave us back was homelessness
and kids who don't go to school
and a lockdown state with numbers that
are high uh then higher than new york
uh and higher than texas and new york
and texas and florida are free
so let's talk about something else that
is getting a lot of controversy
and that's what happens when you get
vaccinated they're talking about a
vaccine passport where if you get
vaccinated maybe go to that game you get
vaccinated maybe go to that
on that plane and if not maybe you don't
governor ron desantis in a state you're
familiar with florida
said this about the concept of vaccine
passports
it's completely unacceptable for either
the government or the private sector
to impose upon you the requirement that
you show proof of vaccine
to just simply be able to participate in
normal society
you want the fox to guard the hen house
i mean give me a break
i think this is something that has huge
privacy implications
it is not necessary to do
he's not waiting to find out what joe
biden's going to do tucker where do you
stand
why is it left to the governor of
florida to say that aren't there 50
republicans in the senate why aren't
they standing on a line with mitch
mcconnell in the center saying
no we're not doing this i'm sorry you're
not allowed in this country because of
hipaa laws you're not allowed to know if
your kids have a sex change
i mean and now they're your private
infra whether you're vaccinated or not
is that information will be in the hands
of the tech companies and that will
determine whether you can participate in
american life
look if you're trying to calm people
down about the idea of vaccines
and make them less vaccine hesitant and
make them you know convince them that
it's not a conspiracy run by bill gates
a conspiracy theory
then you wouldn't even consider doing
something like this i mean the amount of
paranoia and fear and distrust and
social division that this kind of policy
will engender
is impossible to calculate if you wanted
to divide american society even further
you would go ahead and do something
orwellian like this
of course they don't care but where are
the
defenders of i don't know the american
way
in washington i mean they really should
be outraged by this in my opinion
all right and speaking of opinion that's
something that we're going to hear a lot
more of
uh and if you moved your head a little
bit we could actually see the sign
that says tucker carlson today okay
that is right there tucker changed his
name to ocker
tucker we love the new we love the new
set
uh apparently over the weekend you
called in skip adele you've got some
wood paneling this is the official home
now of tucker carlson today right
i like wood wood was alive
i mean what is you know the greatest
building material there is and i like
being surrounded by all types yeah
this is essentially an opportunity to go
deeper and longer with interesting
people i talk less they talk more
everyone learns a lot
super interesting you know i mean these
interviews can go on for quite some time
and if you like
long form and i think there's a place
for it um
it's great and by the way it's not easy
to get not difficult to get i'm not good
at tech
but if you go on to foxnation.com which
i did on saturday
i was expecting a difficult no it's
actually super easy it's the first time
you've gone on fox nation
thanks i have a series i know
you get your shows
because i work here so i have like free
access but i was like i'm going to do it
as everyone else does it it's like
it's not hard and trust me i can barely
operate my ipad
right so they make it easy i heard you
talk about you got a clip last night of
douglas murray you and him
i have some quality time here's some
more
what's important in our society is
change radically and in an ugly
direction
it makes everything political it wants
to politicize everything
it wants to politicize art it wants to
politicize poetry
uh all all of the things that were
meaningful in our lives
have been picked up and spun through
this cycle
of politics
that's great deep thinker and you talked
to him this is that's your first episode
yeah what a genius that guy is i mean
but to talk to him i we we split it up
into a couple of hours yeah it was
amazing by the end of that interview
i was so relieved and reassured about
the future of the
country um yeah he just has this
overview on what's happening and what we
can do about it that
that changed that changed my view so
yeah it was it was wonderful so carlson
we have a few openings this summer on
vacation do you want to fill in on fox
and friends at all that is the
toughest i hope your audience
understands
how hard it is to wake up at three in
the morning and do three hours i am just
filled
with awe and respect and i mean that's a
no
he's turned down the shift every day is
like a telephone
that's why he has coffee with his wife
that's right tucker carlson today
in the new ranch house uh wood grain
studio
is available now on fox nation new
episodes drop mondays wednesdays and
fridays
be like tucker carlson and go to
foxnation.com
to check it out tucker we'll be watching
tonight thank you very much thank you
great to see you and you ainsley see ya
always good to see you now i can see
your full name up there too he's back
he's back to tucker he always singles
you out